Thank you. Thank you uh Tony. That
that's a good introduction. Thank you.
Very very kind introduction. So so here
[clears throat]
you know I'm I'm very happy you know to
to give this talk. So thanks again for
inviting me and um
um so the purpose of the talk is to um
it's a overview of um scientific machine
learning uh from my perspective personal
perspective and also
mention some of our own contributions
along the way uh to to to this. So we
begin with this um um slide where we
have you know on the left side you have
no data and lots of physics or all
physics and on the right side you have
lots of data and no physics
and on the left side that's where you're
going to going to find uh purely physics
informed uh neural networks Gaussian
processes uh operate even operator
learning in fact you can do physics
informed operator learning.
So and then the way that we introduce
the physics is typically there are two
ways. One is a soft way where you modify
the loss function or the score function
whatever it is that you're optimizing
you modify it with the the physics
and the other way is the hard way where
you embed the physical constraints
directly into the the the algorithm. So
the there are these two different ways.
Um and
we'll talk about this. Uh this is also
where you find traditional scientific
computation.
Uh so you know in traditional scientific
computation you have no data. I mean you
have the entire specification of the
physical model and then you uh simulate
uh the physics uh you generate the data
on the other side um then you're going
to have datadriven neuronet networks and
process operator learning purely
datadriven uh so no physics so here you
need need lot lots of data uh in fact
uh and you're also going to find
datadriven scientific computation. So
for instance um you know pod based on on
snapshots and
so on and so forth.
Um
in the middle there is some data and
some physics. So so here you know I'm
going to call this inverse problems. You
can still use neuronet networks, goss
processes
for system identification, parameter
estimation,
uh hidden fields prediction. I'll show
you an example. So these are problems
where you have some data
and some physics and when I say physics,
I mean geometry also. I mean geometry, I
mean uh boundary conditions, right? So
not just the PD.
So you may know the PD but you don't
know the boundary conditions or the
geometry of the problem. Um and then you
have some data to uh make up for that
ignorance of of the physics. So I I I I
happen to think that neuro I mean
neuronet network machine learning in
general is still quite uh unexplored in
this part here the inverse problems and
I think you know there's a lot of
potential for using machine learning in
these kind of problems
now behind all of these uh except for
the left extreme left side
we have the question uh this question is
is the physics in the data because you
are in fact using the data to replace
the physics.
So here there is an important
epistemological question right [snorts]
I mean if you have an infinite amount of
data a thought experiment if you have an
infinite amount of data can you derive
all the physical laws of the universe I
mean can you derive you know um quantum
gravity you know can can you can you
derive a complete uh picture of of the
physics
by using just data. All right. Um I
happen to think [snorts] that the answer
is no because we know in supervised
learning machine learning we have this
uh no free lunch theorems where even if
the if your algorithm is consistent
or universally consistent so consistent
in every situation
uh meaning that if you have an infinite
amount of data you you reach the optimal
predictor.
um is still the the rate of conversions
can be arbitrarily low which means that
you never have enough data. So yeah, if
you had an infinite amount of data you
could do it
but you you you you in fact have you you
you don't have a guarantee of how much
data you need. In fact, you could have
you could need an arbitrarily large
amount of data which which you don't
have. So, so this is uh an important
question but uh but you know empirically
we we we know that in in many cases we
can use the data to recover uh the
physics at least in simple problems or
simple enough problems. So of course I
mean the more complex the problem
becomes the more data you need but uh
but you could still uh use the data to
to
make up for the uh no loss of physics or
or missing physics or incorrect physics
or
whatever. So that's the introduction
slide and then I would like to talk
about each of these things uh as we go.
So the first uh obviously most
well-known algorithm in in scientific
machine learning is the pin. I think
everybody here already knows about pin
or have heard about pin. So this is a
soft approach that is a neuronet network
u and the neuronet network uh in fact
produces a prediction of the solution.
So it's a coordinate neuronet network
like like is usually now referred to or
implicit uh model where the input is the
physical coordinates space and time for
instance and the output is the solution
uh at each point in the physical space.
Uh now using automericic differentiation
you can differentiate this output
and you can compute um
a partial differential equation
um residue.
So you could enforce this residue to be
zero on a selected amount of uh selected
points in the domain. I I cannot use my
pointer here but uh but you can see on
the uh lower left side you can see uh an
example where you're going to have of
course points along the initial
condition points along the boundary
condition lateral boundary conditions.
You're going to have the axis which are
the collocation points and you're going
to have the uh orange dots which could
be data. In fact, you could still have
data or maybe you don't have any data.
So in the purely physics informed
setting that there is no data. So yeah,
so it's a soft approach because you're
going to minimize the loss and you're
going to encourage the neuronet network
to satisfy the initial condition,
boundary condition, and the PD.
uh it's it's not guaranteed to satisfy
exactly
but if you if you can if you have enough
points and you have you know enough
expressive expressive uh network big
enough network
you can uh get very close. So that's why
it's called a soft approach.
And here's an example of course uh very
simple example.
It's um the viscous uh burgers equation.
And what we can see here is the solution
of a pin with eight layers, 20 neurons
each, 200 initial points, 100 binary
points, 20,000 collocation points. It's
very fast. So we do 400 train iterations
iterations and it's very fast to to
train the spin. It's like on GPU
it's about a minute. Okay. And so of
course it's a very simple problem but we
can still we can already see that the
neuron network is able to capture this
uh very sharp transitions in the
solution.
Um and um and and this is typically a
uh basic benchmark right for for for
most numerical methods.
for for hyperbolic problems,
you know, transport problems. So, so the
pin does a very good job here.
Now, it it does not such a good a good
job here. Uh, so this equation here, the
Alink
u you know it is um not a hyperbolic
equation. It's a it's a diffusion
reaction equation. It is stiff quote
unquote in the sense that it it evolves
uh uh this discontinuities very fast. Uh
and and this and the and and the and the
the fact is that the pin cannot
converge. Um
you know if you look at uh the losses
and remember that the losses have
different components. The loss has
different components. There's a loss for
initial points, for residue points,
collocation points, boundary points. If
you look at the components of the loss,
you observe that the boundary loss is
very small. So the boundary conditions
are satisfied.
The residue loss is small, meaning that
the PD is satisfied
because
constant zero is a solution of the PD.
But the initial point, the initial loss
is not satisfied.
So this is the main failure
mode as it's called um of pin is that
you know you have this complicated loss
function with many components
and uh there can be an imbalance between
these uh losses
uh here it's finding a solution of PD
zero but that's not the solution of the
problem.
So so the question is uh how can you fix
that? So there's a big literature on
this. Um one of the approaches is to use
uh weights. So to weight the loss
uh and of course put different weights
on different parts of the loss.
So we we we contributed
an algorithm in this uh setting which is
called self adaptive physics informed
neuronet networks.
uh this is already has you know it was a
few years ago but uh it is u you know
wells cited paper and uh and with this
approach we can solve the alen equation
uh what happens is that we have some
some adaptive weights
on each point not on the entire loss
function but on each point of the domain
uh we can put weights and those weights
are adjusted during training. So they
are you know automatically adjusted
during training and so the the the
network learns what are the critical
parts of the solution. So for instance
here you can see that uh the yellow and
green are the larger weights and the
purple is the small weights and we can
see that the weights are going to grow
early so near t equal to zero and along
where the gradients are you know larger.
So you have these structures forming.
Uh we can also see here down here. Uh so
you can see my pointer right.
So you can see down here on the on the
right um the lower right. You can see uh
the average of the weights of the
residue. These are the weights you're
seeing on the upper left. And the
average of the initial
uh uh condition weights. And the initial
condition weights, the green curve, they
grow much faster in fact than the
residue weights because
you know it's not capturing the initial
condition. So it's going to put a lot of
weight on the initial condition. But you
see the network learns by itself that
that's what the trouble is. I mean it is
the basic idea. So, so if you now run uh
the pin
then you can see that
uh it will now produce a good
approximation uh to to the solution. Uh
on the lower left we have comparison
with some other adaptive waiting methods
but uh so yeah so this is a self
adaptive pin.
Um
the other thing you can do with ping is
you can do par estimation and like I
said so it's an invest problem and and
like I said these invest problems I
believe there is still a lot of
potential okay to to explore and and
what you're seeing here is the the
burgers equation where you're trying to
estimate the [clears throat] viscosity
so you can treat the viscosity as a
parameter in the loss function along
with the weights of the neural network
and then you can um minimize the loss
function
set uh identify the the parameters
uh along with the neural network weights
by minimizing the loss function and you
can use self adapt adaptive weights you
can use all the adaptivity
uh procedures right so here you see an
example where trying to identify the
viscosity from noisy data
On the solution we have 10 runs the
parameters initialized in a in a wide
interval. The true viscosity is 0.01
over pi. And you see that
the all the runs converge to
the true the true value. Uh after some
oscillations they eventually u converge.
uh on the right side you see the the
loss which is also converging.
Um so uh this is a simple example of of
course but uh you know so I think this
is this is a a situation where you have
some data
and you have some physics you're missing
the missing physics here is of course
you don't know the viscosity okay but
you know Burger's equation and in fact
you know the initial condition and you
know the boundary conditions you can
make the problem harder but here you're
missing the viscosity so So you don't
have the entire physics but you have
some data.
So so you can get it. Okay. So you can
find in fact you can find the solution
and the parameter simultaneously. Right.
Okay. The other approach uh you know for
soft physics informed is Gaussian
processes. So uh in this slide we have a
very simple example.
Uh the idea is very in fact is similar
to pins.
um you have the PD and if you have a
linear PD you can differentiate. So you
have a GP to approximate solution. First
of all you have a GP to approximate the
solution just like you have a neuron
network to approximate the solution but
then you can differentiate this GP just
like you use automatic differentiation
to differentiate neuron network. You can
differentiate this GP through kernel
differentiation.
If the PD is linear, you obtain another
GP.
So now you have two GPS, one for the
solution and another for the residue of
the PD in fact for the PD. So you can
fit um
zeros to the residue GP and you can fit
initial condition data, boundary
condition data to the to the first GP
and these GPS are of course jointly
distributed.
Um and then obviously um you you use the
first GP or the posterior mean of the
first GP as the approximation to the
solution and and you can use also the
standard deviation of the first GP
posterior after conditioning on on the
data to
have a me measure of of confidence or
error. So in this particular case we are
we are seeing on the lower left the
absolute difference between the exact
solution of this adection simple
adection equation and the GP post mean
is very low it's very small so it's very
accurate but obviously there is error
and but if you look at the standard
deviation on the right side on the lower
right you're going to see that it's very
correlated very I mean
uh uh extraordinarily in fact correlated
with the the error the absolute
difference. So in practice you don't
know the absolute difference of course
but but you have the GP post serious
standard deviation. So this gives a very
in this case it's a very well calibrated
problem you get a very well calibrated
standard deviation and and and you can
use this as a measure of confidence in
your in your solution. Neuronet networks
don't give you that. Okay.
But you know with GPS you have GPS have
other challenges which is for instance
nonlinear PDS you can solve them with
neuron networks very well like uh de
burgers problem. So nonlinear PD with
GPS
you have a problem because you no longer
have Gaussian processes. So now you have
um more complicated inference problem.
uh and you have you know so essentially
it becomes also less accurate but um
there's also a problem GPS of
scalability if you have a lot of points
so a lot of residue points a lot of
initial points because GPS have a a
computational complexity of n cq where n
is the number of points uh but obviously
there are scalable approximations and
things you can do to to alleviate that
problem.
Next slide is again the soft physics
informed Gaussian process. I'm going to
show you here a different kind of uh
uncertainty quantification.
So the uncertainty here is going to be
introduced by the discretization of the
problem. So here
is you're going to so you have a wave
equation you're going to discretize it
in space and you're going to generate a
system of ODS
as it's often done and then you are
going to solve that system of ODS using
Gaussian process.
Now here we're going to actually use a
common filter to compute the posterior
mean and standard deviation which is a
no of n in the number of time step
discretization. So it so you're going to
discretize in time the system of all
this you know the GP would be n cube in
the number of time steps but we use a
common filter and we get actually O of
N. So this is one of the approaches to
make the approach more scalable. Okay.
But here of course the how fine the
discretization is will affect the
accuracy of the result. So you know if
if you do not discretize enough in space
or in time you're going to have a poor
approximation.
So there is an uncertainty coming from
uh the discretization. So here I'm going
to show you the solution
from a coarse discretization to a fine
discretization. So coarse on the upper
left, fine on the lower right and and
intermediates in between. So so you're
going to see that obviously
um the solution becomes very bad as time
goes on. Uh it starts well but then it
loses track as you know
the the time integration uh proceeds.
And what what you what you see is that
the posterior mean is incorrect. The
posterior mean is the red dashed and and
and the analytical is the is the black.
Well, what you see here is that uh the
posial mean is incorrect. But this
standard deviation
points you to the fact that it's
incorrect on on the on the lower right
the positive standard deviation is zero
essentially.
uh and this the the posterior standard
deviation is in fact larger
the more incorrect the solution is I
mean the post mean so um so that's
another example of well-c calibrated
bijian inference here where you know
your your standard deviation
um can serve as as a as an error
estimator okay essentially So
with Gaussian process you can also do
inverse problems. So, so here uh we're
going to you're going to the unknown
parameter becomes a hyperparameter of
your pryo
along with kernel hyperparameters
and then you are going to use to
maximize the marginal likelihood
to set the the kernel prior
hyperparameters along with the
parameters of the problem that you don't
know.
So here we are trying to find the
velocity of uh the linear direction
problem from sample noisy data. Uh we
run 10 runs
uh and the true velocity is 10 and what
we observe is that in nine out of the 10
cases we converge to the to the true
velocity.
There is um one run that does not
converge
uh it converges to a suboptimal local
minimum but uh but in nine out of 10
cases we able to get a very accurate
estimate uh of the uh velocity. So so
you can use both neuronet networks and
goss process to solve this inverse
problems.
This one is a different kind of in
inverse problem this one here. So we're
going to apply a neural network and this
is a so-called hidden field inverse
problem. So what what what you have here
is the Navia Stokes equation and the
artifact of a scalar a a passive a
passive scaler a passive tracer that
moves along the flow
and then uh obviously you have this
system of PDS and you have four uh
fields. You have the the tracer
concentration. You have the horizontal
velocity, the vertical velocity, and the
pressure. This is a two dimensional flow
problem. There is a cylinder. You see
the cross-section of the cylinder. And
the flow is moving from left to right.
The only information you have is the the
inlet velocity. So, what is the velocity
of the flow coming in from the left? Um
and you have some scared concentration
data,
noisy concentration data.
Um it's not a dense grid on the tracer
concentration field is just some
scattered concentration data. So here
I'm going to use a neural network
along with the Navia Stokes equations
and the defraction equation
um to estimate the velocities and the
pressure without having no information
on the velocities or the pressure also
without having information on the
boundary conditions
either on the walls or on the cylinder.
So you don't know anything about the
cylinder.
uh in fact you you believe it or not you
don't even know the position of the
cylinder so you don't know that the only
thing you have is the SC concentration
data
and the equations and the inlet velocity
so so here I'm showing you the the the
solution
which is very accurate so you're able to
to reproduce this turbulent uh flow
um using um a a neuronet network. Um
this is a reo number 100 which is not
very high but it's already high enough
to produce in fact the
um
the these vortices uh that you see uh
downstream from the cylinder. This is a
well-known problem in computational
fluid dynamics is the famous flow around
the cylinder
and and and and of course this is you
using the velocity and the pressure you
can compute forces on the on the
obstacle on the cylinder this could be
an air air foil uh in aerospace
engineering uh etc. So, so, so this is u
I think it's a very good example of u
you know using neuron networks for for
invest problem. There's no way you can
use traditional numerical methods to to
solve a problem like this. I mean it's
just
no way. Okay.
All right. The other possibility is the
hard possibility. So here I just have a
one one simple example here. uh so this
is called the characteristic informed
neuronet networks. So for hyperbolic
transport problems you can use the
characteristic method
to um in fact um obtain a layer that
enforces the PD. So in this in this
particular case it's a linear vection.
It's very simple but you know it can be
more complex. Uh here what you see is a
layer that contains the velocities
um and and then the output of the
neuronet network is guaranteed to be a
solution
because you in fact you you transform to
the characteristic space with the first
layer and then you do function
approximation of the characteristic
space which is guaranteed to satisfy the
PD. So you just need to of course um
train the network on the initial data or
boundary data. Um but the PD is already
satisfied. So there is no loss uh
physics informed loss. There's no
physics informed loss. There's only data
fitting loss. So this is a regular
neuronet network is trained on you know
just data fitting. Okay. Uh no physics.
So, so this prevents uh unphysical
solutions and also prevents
uh those
imbalances between the different loss
components.
This is an example. Um and here we can
see that the pin starts
degrading at velocity around 40
whereas the characteristics in form
neuron network can still predict well at
velocity 40.
uh at velocity 50
at least with this horizon of training
the characteristic for neural network
starts degrading
but you know at 40
it still produces a very accurate
solution whereas the pin does not so so
this is u just an example of
of that but you know so the idea is that
even if your solution is wrong it's
still a solution of the PD which doesn't
help I know but but this the output
solution is never unphysical the output
solution is never unphysical right so
if you have any questions I mean you can
you can can ask or maybe hold until the
end uh that's that's okay so so next uh
talk about neuro operators uh so we only
talk about datadriven neuro operators
there is also physics informed neuro
operators but here we are just talk just
just going to talk about datadriven
neuro operators so so the idea here is
that you're solving a parametric PD
which means that um it's actually a
family of PDS and and the solutions
corresponding to this range of
parameters becomes a a manifold it's a
solution manifold
and that is a solution operator that
takes you from each parameter to its
corresponding solution. You're
interested in approximating the solution
operator.
Provided that the solution operator
is continuous,
you can approximate it arbitrarily well
with a neuronet network.
So the solution operator typically in a
wellpost problem is is continuous. Okay.
So for instance you take uh the Darcy's
equation and the parameter here is a
function in fact so this parameter can
be a function
uh it's the posity at each location
and then the solution is the fluid
pressure
at each uh location. So by learning the
solution operator
given a new parameter field new given a
new posity profile I can estimate the
the fluid pressure without any weight
updates no no further training so there
is an initial training step which can be
time consuming but once it's trained I
can make predictions very fast so so
that's the you know the idea and of Of
course you can use neuronet networks to
do this. Um you could use Gaussian
processes in principle to do this and of
course you can use more traditional
scientific computation methods including
uh pod bases and and things like that.
Okay. So, so the idea then is that you
have an infinite dimensional space
for the parameter and you have an
infinite dimensional space for the
solution. But you cannot deal with
infinite dimensional objects on a
digital computer. So what you're going
to do is you're going to have to
discretise these functions. Okay? And
once you have these pairs of parameter
and solution
discretized in fact uh pairs of
parameter solution you can train your
new operator and then the testing on a
new discretized again parameter solution
produces
a discretized
uh solution.
So here is again the idea that the
physics is in the data. Okay. I mean,
you might have
an advantage here if you actually don't
know the physics or or the physics you
have is incorrect.
Um, you know, if you try to use a
physics informed approach with incorrect
physics,
of course, you're going to get an
incorrect solution. So, but if you have
a completely datadriven approach,
uh you could then
learn implicitly learn the physics
through the data. With that caveat,
you know that you might need infinite
amounts amounts of data.
Uh but for simple problems, you don't
need infinite amounts of data. Okay? I
mean if the problem is simple enough
simple enough you can have uh a
reasonable amount of data that can solve
that problem. So so that's the idea. Now
this discretization uh introduces an
issue which is um c can we can we call a
neuronet network an operator learner
um if it's
learning the resolution. So it should
not learn the resolution because if it's
learning the resolution then it's a
discrete operator. So it should be in
some sense insensitive to to the
resolution. So here we see on the left
unit which is very sensitive to the
training resolution. If you train if you
train on 64x 64 grids
you only get a good result if you test
on 64x 64 grids.
Whereas on the right you have a fender
operator in a convolution operator where
it's much more flat. You can train on
64x 64 and you can test on 96x 96.
Um
but you know there's a limit of course
you know if if the resolution is too
small you can't get a good result and
but this is more or less the idea. So
there is a big debate right now
uh about uh you know are neuro operators
really neuroop operators is literally
the title of this uh paper where I took
this figure from. So are neuro operators
really neuro operators.
So that's the
uh debate. Uh from a practical point of
view, if you're only testing on the same
resolution that you train, you don't
care. Okay? I mean, you you just don't
care. I mean, if if you are always
testing on the same resolution that you
train, no one cares. Okay? But it's
still
a theoretical question. Okay?
All right. So our contribution in this
arena um uh recently we we have been
working on depot sets which is a
combination of deep nets which is a
well-known neuro operator and deep sets.
So so here um what you can achieve with
this deep sets encoder is um first
an a variable number of samples. So your
resolution training resolution effect
can can vary
you know you can use different
resolutions for your training and also
introduces a permutation invariance
uh bias because these points these
samples from the parameter function
they are permutation variant I mean it
doesn't matter if you sample x1 first
and x2 second or vice versa so the
neuronet network doesn't have to learn
that the problem is permutation variant
in instead you you introduce a an
inductive bias or permutation variance
which allows you to use less data.
Okay. So so that is uh the basic idea.
Um
here you see some uh results uh you know
for a simple nonlinear diffusion
reaction PD the operator learning
problem is to map from f ofx forcing
function to the solution.
So here we are seeing after training the
network on a range of uh
discretization range.
We see the solutions for uh a new
forcing function where discretiz on five
points, 10 points, 20 points and you see
the prediction of the new operator and
you see the exact. So obviously the
error is decreasing. you can go for for
50 100
um on the on on the error becomes very
small. Um indeed you see here the error
plotted the L2 relative L2 error plotted
as a function of the testing resolution
where the two vert vertical dash lines
is the range of training resolution. So
with the sets you can have a a range.
We can see that within the range and in
fact on the right of the range uh the
arrow is flat you know it's it's small
10 to the -3 to 10 the -4 which is small
okay and it's relatively flat so it
agrees with that idea of resolution
invariance obviously on the left as the
number of samples become very small the
error increases Okay.
But you know the I think these are
promising initial results uh for for for
this uh class of operator neuro
operators.
Okay. the last part of the the lecture
which I'll try to do as fast as I can uh
is an it's a it's a it's a yet uh again
a new neuro operator architecture that u
our posa chain is working on and um it's
called incon so it's a new operator for
time evolution problems
where you know modify a unit to have uh
as input uh the time along with the uh
in this case two dimensional fields
um and also the parameters as inputs.
So, you know, we call this the incom
and uh and and here we're going to apply
this to um
a plasma physics problem or plasma
turbulence model which is called the
Hagawa Katani model and um the
Hagawakatani model is a is a very
well-known benchmark for numerical
methods for for plasma turbulence.
Um it's a two-dimensional uh problem
and and it it it models uh different
physical quantities the the plasma
electrostatic potential the electron
density and the electrostatic uh
vorticity.
So here we are using a traditional
numerical code it's called HW2D to
generate the data to train our neuro
operator. And you're seeing down here a
sample of snapshots from from the code
uh after the turbulence phase has be
begun. So you we we we discard the
initial transient phase and then we take
only the the turbulent uh phase.
So we generated 320 evolutions with
different choices of the parameters
uh on 128 by 128 grid. That's the
training grid and a step size of 0.005.
This these are you know of course
normalized time in in space
appropriately. So um we do this for
40,000 time steps. We take 240 for the
for for the training set and 80 for the
testing.
and and then you run the infin auto
reggressively. So you you start at the
initial uh snapshot you predict t plus
delta t and then you use t plus delta t
as the input to predict t plus 2 delta t
and and go on like this. So the network
is trained and then you give a new
snapshot from the test data
and then we compare here the numerical
code with the incom prediction. Uh it
they agree very well until a certain
time and after that it starts diverging
you know the numerical code and the in
contradiction but obviously um it's a
it's a chaotic system. So you know
even minor deviation is going to grow
right. So you don't expect uh in fact uh
that they're going to agree uh forever
but the agreement is very good and also
the important thing here is that the
influence time for each snapshot
is a fraction of a second whereas
obviously the code takes a long time
okay to to produce an evolution. So with
this trained network we can produce an
evolution
very fast. Okay.
Um
the important thing for for plasma uh
you know whether in astrophysics or in
fusion
is the statistics of the evolution not
necessarily the fields themselves. So
they are interested in things like the
turbulent particle flux or the so-called
primary sync
and here we are comparing this quantity.
So we we compute the evolution and then
we compute the quantities based on the
evolution and we compare them. So here
we compare them with the numerical code
so-called truth. Here what we observe is
that
um the general
uh frequency behavior is very close. I
mean so the uh the frequency content um
is is is very close
even even if the time domain evolution
does not match exactly uh because of the
chaotic behavior but the the frequency
content is is is very close. We also
compute the mean and the standard
deviation of the time evolution of these
quantities and they also match
uh quite well. In fact, we do it between
300 and 600
uh in time whereas we train only between
200 and 300.
So that that's another way of uh
testing.
Um we also compute the um the the f
transform of the of this quantity
squared the magnitude squared of the um
vorticity here which is typically used
also as a as a benchmark. And we see
here that um we match the expected power
law behavior of this quantity uh as a
function of wave number.
Finally uh we can use this architecture
for inverse problems. So here we are
using some data some evolution but you
know in fact we're using very small
amounts of data. we are taking some uh
pairs of t and t plus delta t um
randomly from from from the evolution
um and then we are uh finding the
parameters by gradient descent on the
input of the trained neuronet network.
So you don't don't retrain the neuronet
network. The the neuron network is not
retrained.
It is actually only the inputs
parameters which are modified
um by gradient descent. And we can see
that in a relatively fast amount of time
200 seconds we are able to in fact uh
get a a good approximation. We can see
the same thing here um where we repeated
the procedure several times and we
plotted the scatter plot and we can see
that obviously as the amount of data
increases from two pairs to eight pairs
and 32 pairs the results improve.
We can also see that kapa 0 is very easy
to estimate. In fact, you only need two
pairs to do a relatively good job. I
mean a very good job. um and CPB is next
and the other two are more difficult
>> [snorts]
>> uh to to predict but still there's a
strong signal here. I mean there's
there's a strong signal. So
um so that is uh what I had about uh
this. So just to finalize then you know
a little uh ad here for our scientific
machine learning lab. Um so we have been
doing this for 5 years now. Uh it is
almost five years. It is um the first
lab the firstatic lab of Tamitz. So it
was a pilot lab and we um have a
research mission, education mission.
There are seminars, workshops,
demos. So you can go to the website and
check this out. Uh we have this seminar
series where in fact Yong Su was the the
the speaker uh this Monday, this past
Monday. So you can see all this
information there. So I mean that's it.
So you know now
I think I I hope I was quick enough in
time
>> and uh we could
um answer questions.
>> Yeah, thanks for the wonderful talks. Uh
we have several questions in the chat
room already. So I'm going to read them
uh one by one.
Uh Connor asked how does validating the
learn operators compare to validating
physics based models solve with
traditional numerical methods.
>> So the question is how you compare the
results of the operator learning with
the traditional numerical methods. Is
that the question?
>> Yeah, I think so. So, so well
you have traditional numerical methods
of parametric PDS
um and but typically
[clears throat] traditional numerical
methods apply to single single PD
right um
uh now with reduced order modeling you
know POD bases etc you can actually
solve parametric PDS the same way that
you solve with neuro operators
uh it it is very interesting in fact to
compare these approaches. Um we have not
uh I I I'm not aware of any simulation
study that does a very thorough
comparison.
Uh we do have uh pod depotonets which is
a hybrid sort of a hybrid where you take
the the pod basis and you use as a trunk
of the of the net and then you only
train the the branch of the deep net. So
so they call it pod depotonet.
Um so there are possibilities of
hybridizing these approaches in fact and
there are possibilities of comparing
them but I I I'm not aware of any
systematic comparison you know so maybe
maybe you guys can do it Lawrence
Livermore
but u
>> so
>> can I clarify the question sorry
>> um I'm I'm I'm wondering if or um if
there's strategies for training neural
operator on some set of data and then
deploying it on practice where you don't
in practice where you don't necessarily
have a guarantee that the operating
conditions are going to be similar to
the training data. Um seems like people
know how to address this issue for
physics models because you don't worry
about generalization and I'm wondering
if there's a strategy to you know have
some bounds that says your your model's
going to work in practice.
It's the same thing with any
uh datadriven machine learning approach.
If if your test data
does not correspond to your training
data, then you're going to have a
distribution shift or out of
distribution problem. And uh of course
in all the simulations I showed, the
testing data comes from the same place
as the training data. But you know if
that's not the case then you're going to
have to adopt some other strategies.
It's exactly the same problem that you
have in computer vision or natural
language processing or or any datadriven
machine learning. You're right. If you
have the physics informed uh component
then um well [clears throat] that
alleviates this issue but the physics
component also can be incorrect.
So, you know, the physics component
could be incorrect
and and so there's no really no way to
get out of this except for sound
experimental design. So, you know, if
you if you have sound experimental
design, data collection, etc. You you
make sure that your your test data is as
close as possible to train it. So,
that's the answer I I can give.
>> Thanks.
Okay.
>> Okay. Uh the next question is from
Johans. Um what training strategy do you
use for learning the time dependent
operator in in con?
>> What training strategy? So so this is um
you know it's traditional uh Adam
you know optimization.
Um it it it takes time. This is a big
network. So it it takes many hours of
GPU but the idea is that once you it's
trained you can make very quick uh
predictions
>> predict the evolution.
>> Yes.
>> Sorry I meant more uh specifically um if
you're learning the operator for a
single simulation time step or a
userdefined time step or if you're
training over different size time steps.
>> Yes. So so the the operator is trained
to predict uh a given time in the
future. So you know the time is an
input.
So you know given the initial snapshot
you can make predictions at any time in
the future in principle but uh so it's
it's quite it's totally flexible but
[clears throat]
uh in the uh video I showed we are using
it auto reggressively. So we are
predicting you know t 0 plus delta t.
Then we take t 0 plus delta t to predict
t 0 + 2 delta t. And when we use it auto
reggressively but but the operator can
make a prediction of any time given the
initial condition can make a prediction
at any time. It's only when you want to
have an evolution that you need to do it
auto reggressively.
So
>> okay but the loss is just uh with
adjacent
>> the loss is is is is just between the
initial condition and the snapshot at
time t.
>> So you're going to you're going to train
it on several times.
Um you're going to train it on the
entire evolution effect but the the loss
is between the the the prediction at
time t and the snapshot at time t.
So
>> okay. Yes.
>> So um Elon asked a a series of question
actually. So how long in time was the
Hzawa worker tenny trained relatively to
the nearon of exponents and how far in
time do the statistics agree for the
model and can we use time scales much
longer than the neopon of time for this?
So uh as we saw the um up to 20 time
steps um the evolution was the agreed
well I mean not necessarily the the
fields agree but the statistics agree I
mean the statics statistics agree over
this uh horizon uh if you increase the
horizon there will be uh there might be
less agreement uh I don't have that data
here But uh yes obviously if you if you
if you do a long roll out um you start
accumulating more more errors but uh the
the the the fre the frequency response
is is is very close and the mean and
standard deviation also very close uh
over this time interval. Um,
I'm not sure if that was a question, but
>> uh, if I if I could just like kind of
clarify, I mean, you said very correctly
that, um, what people ultimately are
really interested in are things like
fluxes and and what, you know, what the
mean is and what the standard deviation
is. So,
>> um, you know, I guess what I'm what I'm
wondering I'm have like a couple of kind
of related questions. one is if you
trained it for a very long time, would
that help? And but I assume the answer
is not really because in terms of like
point-wise convergence because of this
butterfly effect that's happening. Um
but but then there's the more important
question of how well do the statistics
agree as we go further and further in
time because it may very well be that
you capture like dynamics on the
attractor and so then the statistics are
great. [clears throat] Um and
then there's kind of like normally for
these types of simulations people use
the erotic theorem to tell to to collect
statistics and they'll tell you that you
know
>> use what I'm sorry
>> the erotic theorem
>> erotic theorem tell you that a time
average gives you the average that
you're that you care about
>> right
>> um right
>> whereas here I think you might actually
have a lot of statistical information
and you don't even necessarily need to
run your simulation for a long time like
you just already have statistical
information about
>> Right. Right. That's a good point. Yes,
that's a good point.
>> So So it's sort of like even if it
agreed for short times, you may not need
to run it for long times to tell me
>> if it's erodic. Yes, I agree. If if it's
erodic, then yeah, I mean you you you
can capture that those statistics over
over a short window. Yes.
>> So yeah. So that's what what I'm trying
to ask is to what extent do you think
well maybe maybe you need to look a
little closer at the data but like to
what extent are these things actually
satisfied this would be kind of exciting
if if you did
>> right right
>> so thanks thanks for for the input I
mean I I this is a work in progress so
I'm showing you you know some very
recent results so it's a work in
progress we have collaborators uh in the
institute of fusion science ES in at UT
Austin and uh you know they are helping
us at with uh the physics of the problem
and um
but this is uh yes I mean this is a good
question I mean uh I
I'll take this question to to our
collaborators.
This is not a finished uh work. It's not
a finished job. So the preprint
hopefully will be out at some point uh
soon, but this is still work in
[clears throat] progress. So I'll be
happy to share the the preprint with all
of you when it's ready.
So
>> okay,
uh sounds good. I think this are all the
questions. I hope I didn't miss anyone
and I guess we can call a discussion.
Let's thank Elisus for sharing his
excellent research with us today.
Um I will stop.
>> It's my pleasure. It's my pleasure. Yes.